[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a sky news special on the war in
ukraine live from la viv in the west of
the country
tonight rescuers are trying to reach
hundreds of people feared dead after a
theater was bombed in mariupol
civilians bear the brunt as russian
forces failed to advance around here
western intelligence suggests the
invasion has largely stalled on all
fronts and ukraine claims a fourth
russian general has been killed
also ahead president zielinski visits a
hospital in kiev to meet those injured
in the war
and how the conflict in ukraine is
causing ireland to question its
traditional neutrality
[Music]
hello good evening we're live in la viv
in western ukraine it is day 22 of
russia's invasion a campaign which
according to western intelligence has
stalled on virtually all fronts but the
ukrainian people continue to pay the
price for russia's conflict in mariupol
a rescue effort is underway after the
bombing of a theater where more than 1
000 people were thought to be taking
shelter we'll get more on that in just a
moment but
first let's take you live to new york at
an emergency meeting of the un security
council to discuss the humanitarian
crisis in ukraine
we'll take you there of course as soon
as that happens
well let's get the very latest then from
martha kellner what can we expect
yeah this is an emergency meeting of the
un security council called by the uk and
five other countries to address the
worsening humanitarian situation in
ukraine they also want to address
what they say is a risible situation
that situation is this russia which is
also a permanent member of the un
security council like the uk has drafted
what they say is a humanitarian
resolution
on ukraine they say this is about
addressing the escape of innocent
civilians from ukraine but that draft
document doesn't make any mention of the
war itself or indeed russia's role in
this
invasion i was speaking to a member of
the uk delegation earlier they said this
humanitarian resolution put forward by
russia is outrageous they say that
russia is clearly the aggressor in this
situation and they want to make that
clear when this meeting happens we
believe it's just about to start and
today they say that calls for a
ceasefire by russia in this draft
document are outrageous because russia
has repeatedly broken ceasefire
agreements already so this meeting
really
is about an attempt to
dictate the narrative in this situation
they don't want russia who will also
have the opportunity to speak this
afternoon to be able to to put forward
their stories
of fake news they instead want to draw
upon what the the uk ambassador uh
barbara woodward the ambassador to the
un uh says are some of the worst
atrocities being committed by russia in
this war we expect her for example to
mention the bombing in mariupol um of
the theater where innocent civilians
were sheltering we also expected to
mention the attack on the maternity
hospital and to reflect the plight of
those three million ukrainian refugees
you'd expect this to be a heated meeting
though because the russian ambassador to
the un versi navencia will also have the
opportunity to speak he's repeatedly
decried reports um of russian attacks on
civilians in ukraine as fake news they
say it's simply not true that russia is
the aggressor here so you can expect to
hear two competing narratives there but
certainly the uk ambassador to the un
barbara woodward says that she wants to
get the reality of the situation out
there in this security meeting before
russia have the chance to dictate the
narrative
martha looks like they're just getting
themselves settled we will of course
listen in to more of that in a bit a
little bit later on in the meantime in
the capital kiev attacks have continued
in residential areas but any major
russian advance seems to have stalled
one person was killed others injured
after an intercepted missile hit a
residential area this morning while
three weeks into this conflict the will
to defend the city remains strong and
ukrainian resistance has kept russian
forces to the outskirts our special
correspondent alex crawford reports now
from kiev
the terror caused by these attacks
cannot be overstated their life's work
and all their possessions blown away in
an instant
by chance the family weren't here
and they're still very much in shock
i'm so sorry
this is the kitchen
that is utterly destroyed the russian
troops have stopped short of entering
kiev but they're wreaking horror inside
the homes of its residents from afar
devastation here the windows just blew
in he says
any stalling of the russian offensive
means nothing to those at the end of
their missiles
i don't even know how to describe this
michael says
i don't have the words
he pauses he can't quite find strong
enough phrases for what his family's
going through right now
there is no humanity here
this is not war with some army he says
humans just eliminating other humans
this is an atrocity for which no judge
would ever find any justification
it's madness he says
and few right now would disagree with
him
on the other side of the street his
neighbors took the full brunt of the
blast the front gardens now are 15
15-foot deep crater this has landed
right in the middle of a very very
suburban area all around here are
residential homes
many of which were still occupied and
this is exactly what the international
criminal court is investigating a
potential war crime
we're shown the remnants of the missile
they're desperate here to ensure those
who attack them are held accountable
the blast has made this home's front
entrance impassable
so we're taken in through one of the
damaged windows
the russian soldiers seem to have been
held back from encircling the main city
but they're now resorting to long-range
attacks which are indiscriminate and
terrifying
this is
just utterly a whole family house just
reduced to ruins and rubble every room
is like this with
holes blasted through it
how safe do you feel
living here now
of course i don't feel safe here he says
where is safe now there's shooting
bombing rockets hitting us we live here
but we know it's very dangerous here
few feel safe in a capital where random
strikes can happen anywhere anytime
ukrainian defenses have somehow held off
the russian forces from their main city
but they can't stop the horror unfolding
here
[Laughter]
this is the raw pain of knowing someone
you love has gone and your life will
never be the same
it's heartbreak being replayed all over
ukraine
this bombardment may be a desperate
attempt to break the capital spirit
russian troops look like they're
struggling to complete their
strangulation of the capital anytime
soon
but for both sides kiev is everything
and that might mean more erratic and
wretched war actions ahead
alex crawford sky news in kiev
well possibly as part of that
strangulation russian airstrikes have
also targeted a food storage warehouse
on the outskirts of kiev nbc's richard
engel has been on the ground there and
inside the destroyed building
russia has now clearly resorted to siege
warfare it has surrounded the city of
mariopol and here in kiev it seems that
russia wants to starve people out this
was one of the country's biggest food
storage facilities and it's completely
destroyed there were 50 000 tons of food
here and the way it worked is food would
come from all over the country
be stored here trucks would pick it up
and then distribute it to the areas all
around kiev
and it wasn't just bombed once this was
no accident you could say well maybe the
russians hit it by accident it's a large
place it was hit twice and then another
food storage facility just about a mile
from here was also attacked so three
strikes seems like it could not have
been a coincidence and that russia is
attacking civilians it's surrounding
cities
and it's trying to starve people
angle there well the uk defense
secretary has accused russia of playing
dirty tricks after he was targeted by an
impostor posing as the ukrainian prime
minister ben wallace said he became
suspicious and ended the call after what
he described as misleading questions mr
wallace was in warsaw today where he
announced new military support to help
protect polish airspace
well the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky has visited a hospital in kiev
to meet those injured in the war he
spoke to hospital staff and patients
including a family who had come under
russian attack while they were trying to
flee from a village on the outskirts of
the capital
he also met an injured reservist and the
driver of the killed journalist brent
renault
well are we starting to see the signs of
progress in talks between russia and
ukraine despite the bombings both sides
are continuing to negotiate via video
link there are reports that any peace
deal could see ukraine renounce its bid
to join nato and promise not to allow
foreign military bases or weaponry into
the country in exchange for protection
from allies such as the us uk and turkey
west guys aleister bunkel joins me now
with more uh bring us up to date then
alastair um emmanuel macron also hoping
to speak to both presidents today
yeah the french president is looking to
speak to the ukrainian russian
presidents tonight uh emmanuel macron
has been
in regular contact with both to try and
find some sort of diplomatic way forward
as have other leaders but the french
leader has been quite key to that we do
see more promising
signs coming from both sides i was
speaking to western officials earlier on
today who suggests that both sides are
taking the talks very seriously in their
opinion
but
they believe there's also very big gaps
between the two there have been reports
that a 15-point piece plan has been put
down for consideration so
what might that involve and what sort of
negotiations are we looking at
well one is the option that ukraine
might declare neutrality what does that
mean well there are a number of
european states
that are neutral switzerland obviously
famously uh but also ireland uh finland
sweden
malta as well austria and what it means
is that they won't then join a military
alliance like nato
and they would pledge not to get
involved in any foreign conflicts and
not to have any foreign militaries
based within ukraine so for example
the united states could not place a
large number of u.s forces in ukraine or
perhaps even nuclear weapons if they
wanted to as they do elsewhere in europe
so that is the issue of neutrality that
seems to be on the table another issue
that is almost certainly up for
discussion
is the future of the disputed regions of
the donbass and also crimea uh crimea
was annexed by russia in 2014
and donetsk and lehansk in the donbass
had been the subject of conflict ever
since then i was at a cemetery earlier
on today if you think this conflict has
only started in the last couple of weeks
that's not true
russian and ukrainian soldiers rather
have been dying ever since 2014
fighting in those areas so what would
happen to them well the ukrainians want
them back they believe that those areas
are part of ukraine and that they should
have them back the russians obviously
feel the opposite and actually just
after the russian invasion three weeks
ago
there was a vote in the duma in moscow
the russian parliament uh to declare uh
donetsk and the hanks independent so
obviously the future of those regions of
ukraine would be up for negotiation as
well
and then there's a lot more else besides
so
a lot to work through um
depending on who you talk to
you get different answers as to how
close they are to some sort of ceasefire
and the language has certainly ratcheted
up between the u.s president and the
russian leader
joe biden yesterday declaring president
putin a war criminal uh one mr putin
yesterday also talking about scum and
traitors and the need for for
purification it's not a great backdrop
is it for peace talks alastair
no president biden's uh words were aimed
at the russian president president
putin's words which you just quoted
there were aimed at the russian people
and people within russia itself who were
not supportive of this cause of of uh
president putin's cause really dangerous
words very very chilling for uh people
who live in russia and who might not
support
this invasion the military invasion has
all but stalled that is the opinion of
most western militaries they have failed
to even encircle kiev the capital let
alone actually move ground forces inside
or even uh take out the leadership the
president zelinski and his aides
they have stalled in most other areas as
well we're starting to see
small but nonetheless ukrainian advances
or recapturing of land don't
underestimate the russians though they
still have uh force power behind them
they still have military might and they
still have the capability if they want
to and it looks like they might want to
to flatten cities and to carry on this
bombardment of urban centers for much
longer if they need to
yes and uh certainly alistair we heard
the u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken talking about the prospect of
mercenaries joining the fight possibly
from syria so that is also of concern
alastair thank you
so let's get uh more analysis then on
the ground let's get the very latest now
with kamali melbourne at the sky news
center
well i'm joined by air vice marshal sean
bell who's an advisor at the universal
defense and security solutions
organization sean thanks so much for
being with us so we've seen this map for
a number of days now with russian forces
making advances but many people will be
thinking that it looks as if the russian
forces have stalled is that a fair
assessment of what's happened
well i think we've all become addicted
to some of these pictures of seeing how
the red grows as the russian invasion
progresses and yet as you say it hasn't
seemed to have changed much now
the very language you use there i think
is telling um stalled implies that the
russians are having trouble it implies
some hope for from ukraine and and
that's one explanation another
explanation obviously is that you've got
the russian goliath to the ukrainian
david and actually what's happening here
is a massive resupply as russia prepares
itself with fuel almonds food etc
preparing for its next push on its
strategic priorities and what does it
tell us with the map being like this and
being sort of static at this point about
how well the ukrainians are defending
territory that they hold yeah i think
the ukrainians are clearly doing an
outstanding job they're massively
outnumbered but of course it's not just
the military it's also civilian
population who i've taken to arms and
they are proving incredibly resilient
incredibly courageous against a very
determined adversary and of course
they've managed to pull um the russians
into the urban fight which of course
favors the the ukrainians i've also seen
a little bit of pushback so they are uh
mounting some fight backs as well which
tactically might not be strategically
significant but are absolutely causing
the russians to think twice because
rather than uh owning the agenda the
russians are being pushed back by
counter-attacks which is brilliant back
to moscow but definitely stopping them
from getting further in that's right
which keeps them keeps them guessing
let's take a look at where there has
been some movement in this war uh we
know that the city of kirsten in the
south has been taken and of course there
was a bombing on the city of mario paul
yesterday just talk us through the
strategy do you think we understand is
happening for the south of the country
right now yeah the difficulty is we've
got to get inside putin's head which is
very difficult to do but most likely is
that obviously to the north keep would
be a strategic priority but also if you
look back 200 years russia owns the
whole of this coast and therefore if
you're subscribed to the view that putin
hails back to those uh days of the
former soviet union then actually what
he's trying to do is is take the whole
coast again and as the first step of
that he would want to link crimea to the
south to mother russia and of course
that would explain the ribbon of land up
there the problem is with mario paul
still uh causing a difficulty for him
that's undoubtedly going to be a
priority and if you look to the west
odessa is another one of his uh i would
expect it to be a strategic priority the
challenge there is it's so far away it's
a thousand miles away as the crow flies
from russia so i think we're seeing some
of the naval um
ships and uh armaments massing to try to
give odessa a bit of a a hard time as
well okay sean i do appreciate the
assessment thank you very much for that
well let's talk more about odessa shall
we russian warships have been spotted
off the shore of that strategic port
city there are fears that the city may
be in line as a major target as we heard
there ukraine's third largest city is
strategically important of course to
vladimir putin if he can take that he
can cut off the country from the sea
that's ukraine of course people have put
sandbags on the beaches they've blocked
doorways they've blocked windows and
roads and huge steel crosses have been
placed in the streets too designed to
stop tanks and military vehicles in
their tracks let's hear more now from
our correspondent there nick martin
well we woke up this morning to to
dreadful news uh that that looked like
was coming out of merit poll there was a
there was a shelter there with hundreds
of people inside and uh
we know because we've seen pictures of
that shelter with the words children
written in russian on either side of the
end points of that an indication from
the sky
to anybody that this is not a target and
then there were some reports overnight
that that building had been hit and for
a period of time there was a lot of
worry about the men women and children
who were inside there and
you know what had happened to them and
then this morning some official reports
from the ukrainian authorities
suggesting that it had been hit
but that there that they had all
survived now we're trying to just get a
few more details some evidence some
picture that'll filter through as to
exactly what the situation is there but
if that's true and if that pans out then
that has been a miraculous escape and i
suppose that that writing on on the
floor is particularly telling that is
how desperate they are in mario paul now
there is no more
they can do than appeal to the humanity
of their enemies by writing the words
children in massive white letters on the
ground to say please do not bomb this
building we are not the enemy and yet it
was struck this morning here in odessa
just a few hundred miles to the west
here another key city port here
we were walking up by sounds of an
explosion it rattled the windows now
we've got no more information other than
the sound of it we don't know whether
that was defensive outgoing fire from
the ukraine military or whether that was
something that had been fired in from
the black sea and had landed somewhere
and we felt the aftershocks that's the
situation we're in here in odessa to all
intents and purposes it is quite quiet
here today people are getting on with
their everyday business but there are
huge defenses being put up now because
it is inevitable i think that at some
point the russians will try and have a
go at this uh key port city and there
are still families who have stayed here
there's a play park in the city center
that we'll go into in a minute there's
their children playing on swings there
are parents taking their children out
for walks the markets are open
people you get the sense of trying to
get things in while they can because the
situation can change very quickly
and we've seen in mario paul
further up the coast in uh mikhail
another port city the shells starting to
land there as well and these port cities
obviously strategically very important
to the russian military so
early signs here in odessa although we
can't really be sure what those
explosions were this morning but it
didn't sound good from where i was
sitting and all the city can do is kind
of fortify itself and prepare for what
might come
nick martin who i spoke to a little
earlier well arnold schwarzenegger has
made an appeal directly to the russian
people and russian troops also in
ukraine telling them they are being lied
to by their
government i'm speaking to you today
because there are things that are going
on in the world that have been kept from
you terrible things that you should know
about you see
ukraine did not start this war
neither did nationalists or nazis
those in power in the kremlin started
this war i regret to tell you
that thousands of russian soldiers that
have been killed
well this is a sky news special on the
war in ukraine coming up i'll be
speaking to a former prime minister of
finland and hearing how the war is
leading ireland to consider its military
neutrality
[Music]
i am there to speak truth to power one
question to ask the questions that
people want to answer
when i'm interviewing a politician it's
a more rapid fire but this is not this
is a conversation the format of the show
so we're going to have an hour-long
interview show once a week on a thursday
night it's at 9pm it's a moment to press
pause on this frenetic pace of news and
just reflect on things and when we do
have a politician on the show you might
see them interviewed by me in a
different way than you perhaps normally
see it what they do
why they do it if i can find some of
that and bring it onto sky news i'd be
really happy
indian government is confirming that
they are now engaged with russia's
soldiers
air raid sirens fill the airways in the
distance artillery rains down it feels
very close to the center of
there's one they found this devastation
to their apartment
lots of people live here quite a few of
the windows of the houses have been
blown out by the blast
and it feels that it's changing each day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
can you go away
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
well this st patrick's day ireland's
long-standing neutrality is being hotly
debated the war in ukraine and the
arrival of thousands of refugees has
prompted calls for the policy to be
scrapped and for ireland to finally send
lethal equipment to the ukrainians
ireland correspondent stephen murphy has
more
the sunflower joined the shamrock and
yellow and blue tinged the green as the
first st patrick's day parade in three
years took place in dublin
members of the ukrainian community led
the parade with a message of solidarity
[Music]
the russian invasion has seen thousands
of refugees welcomed here and it's also
open to debate on one of the central
planks of ireland's identity its
neutrality
the javelin anti-tank missile being
fired by irish soldiers in county
wicklow ireland has a small stockpile of
the weapon but won't send any to ukraine
because ireland is a neutral country
it's a policy almost as old as the irish
state ireland was even neutral during
world war ii
now though with war in europe once more
it's suddenly being challenged
[Music]
these are members of the army ranger
wing ireland's special forces cahill
berry used to be one of them now he's a
politician calling for a real debate on
neutrality absolutely to be honest it's
long past time and the situation ukraine
has really focused our minds it's
probably a defining moment really and
because that's remember russia has
threatened ireland as a member of the eu
for for slapping sanctions on the
kremlin and they could become very very
aggressive towards ireland in the next
few weeks it's important that we're able
to defend ourselves ireland has taken in
thousands of ukrainian refugees and is
spending more than 30 million euro in
aid
but when it comes to military equipment
it's restricted to non-lethal things
like body armor and rations
since the invasion of ukraine ireland's
military neutrality has been under
scrutiny like never before the irish
government says such a long-standing
policy can't be changed overnight but it
does now accept that it's up for debate
i think there's a there's certainly an
openness now in ireland uh to discuss
issues around common security and
defense in a way that is more proactive
and more open to
to to a change in policy and i think the
irish public will
will be comfortable with that given what
we're seeing and the brutality that
we're seeing coming from russia in
ukraine right now
opinion is divided on the streets of
cork home to the country's naval base
i'm all fire neutrality aim i don't want
us to be giving that up or sacrificing
that in any way shape or form
when you see what's going on in ukraine
no no i think it's time to make a change
you know it's uh
we we need to mature ourselves i think
and and come along you know i disagree
totally absolutely keep our neutrality
absolutely
yeah
for now ireland remains in a crisis of
conscience treading the line between its
much cherished neutrality and making a
more deadly contribution to the defense
of ukraine stephen murphy sky news in
dublin
[Applause]
well let's show you the scene now in new
york where an emergency meeting of the
un security council is underway ahead of
a vote tomorrow as you can see
humanitarian aid is key to this and
there is the who director general
thanks to donors
contingency fund for emergencies
by additional funding
from the un
central emergency response fund surf
however
to sustain the response
we call on donors to fully fund the
united nations emergency appeal
as the under secretary general said
it's only 36 percent so far funded
we thank those donors who have already
pledged funding to meet the needs of
people in ukraine as the under secretary
general said and third
so far
although ukraine is rightly the focus of
the world's attention
i urge you
not to lose sight of the many other
crises in which people are suffering
in afghanistan
more than half the population is in need
with widespread malnutrition and
clearly there are some very critical
issues for the people of ukraine uh food
in those conflict areas being won
medicines as well which is no doubt why
he is there uh giving his assessment we
are expecting to hear from the u.s
ambassador to the u.n shortly so we'll
keep an eye out for that during this sky
news special program on the war in
ukraine ukraine but we will also talk
about the chances of a negotiated end to
the conflict with the former prime
minister of finland
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
and here is linda thomas greenfield u.s
representative to the u.n
they reported terror
the terror that russia is inflicting
across ukraine on the ukrainian people
russia will be held accountable for its
atrocities
there's only one way
one way
to end this madness
president putin
stop the killing
withdraw your forces
leave ukraine once and for all
yesterday i listened to presidents
president zielinski's speech to the
united states congress and i was so
moved by his words his bravery and his
calls for help
and for peace
immediately afterward president biden
announced another 800 million dollars in
security assistance to help ukraine
defend itself
that's more than one billion dollars in
the past
week alone
we're not doing this by ourselves our
allies and partners are fully committed
to surging assistance to the ukrainians
and we are grateful to all of our allies
and partners who have opened their
borders and their hearts and welcome
ukrainian refugees
we're also going to continue to provide
humanitarian relief to support people
within ukraine and those who have been
forced to flee
including the 186 million dollars in
additional assets assistance that
secretary blinken announced on tuesday
here at the united nations we believe
the best way to address the humanitarian
crisis is through a resolution in the un
general assembly
the resolution in the general assembly
will reflect the views of the
overwhelming majority of u.n member
states and ukraine itself
the international court of justice
issued a profound and important order
yesterday to the russian federation
and we call on russia to comply
immediately
so far russia has clearly violated
international law by violating the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
russia's brutal tactics have killed
civilians well we will return to that
very shortly but right now i do want to
bring in the former prime minister of
finland uh professor alexander stubb
good to see you
and before we came to the u.s ambassador
there she was talking about the incident
in mario paul where it appears a russian
attack struck at the theater uh where
people were taking shelter the the
building clearly labeled with the world
children on um i know you were
instrumental in bringing about a
ceasefire in georgia
how badly does this country need a
ceasefire right now
but it's one of these moments when you
know idealism meets realism
i just don't see that ceasefire coming
and the reasons are very simple i think
the stakes for vladimir putin are too
high in georgia it was fairly easy to do
that in five days
but i think in ukraine he's looking for
a big war and a big piece and to be
honest if i was president zelensky there
will be very little that you can
compromise on at the moment
do you think um
actually the world has already caused so
much harm to president putin he feels
like he's got nothing to lose is that
why he's after a big war as you put it
well i think you know he has a stated
aim and that is historical great russia
which for him
includes belarus and and ukraine so
that's his sort of vision he wants to
create his own legacy you know he wants
to be there with the stalins and the
ivan the terribles and peter the great
so
of russia as a great leader and i don't
think he will do anything that stands in
his way to stop it and and the problem
of course is that he can't lose face and
he knows that so therefore you know
we're into the fourth week in this war
and he's not looking extremely good and
probably getting increasingly desperate
as well
so so what are his options now what you
know what will his end game look like
it's very difficult to say i mean i
think there are three options in this
conflict as there quite often are one is
the withdrawal of russian troops
um obviously he's not looking for that
the other one is to split ukraine into
two eastern and west
ukraine and the ukrainians will never
allow that to happen and thirdly is that
he goes all the way and tries to take
over ukraine so i think all of the
options i mean the first one is is the
one that i'd love to see but the two
other ones are are quite horrific uh to
be honest uh but you know as i said
earlier you know i think this is going
to be a protracted long-term conflict so
we're not talking only about weeks but
most probably months
well it is already horrific as you know
so how do you hold on to a nation
when they begin to hate you
uh for putin
you know obviously you have a couple of
things there you have to remember that
in the dna of of russian culture and
history is this sentiment that the rest
of the world is against russia and
russia is isolated and surrounded you
know attacked from the east by the
mongols in the olden days and now by
served formerly by the nazis and not now
by the westerners so there is this sort
of psyche that you know what's going on
as we we have to fight for for russia
and russian identity but of course it's
going to be a combination of things so
one is the sanctions um you know country
that is moving towards a potential
default
the other one is the fact that ukraine
might be able to push push back but in
russia what you need is basically a
bottom-up
movement to get rid of any leader that
that you have and i i think this has to
come from the inside we can't force
change
well what about that idea of pushing
back then how do you see the ukrainians
fighting this and how do you reckon
they've gone so far and how does it
compare with what finland did back in
1939
yeah i mean there are some elements
obviously of the winter war
1939 lasted for
101 days and then there's this sort of
sentiment
almost of heroic nostalgia when we're
watching the ukrainians fighting and the
parallels are there and are not the
parallels that are is that when you're
attacked by a big aggressor for us it
was a soviet union for ukraine it's
russia your sort of sentiment of
defending and protecting your country
goes beyond the call of duty so to speak
whereas the attacker in other words the
russian soldiers some of them are
wondering you know what are we actually
doing here why are we doing this
the second one is that they are now
being fed
with arms
with financial aid with humanitarian aid
and the longer this goes on the more
convinced i am
that actually ukraine and president
zielinski
can push back
and in that sense things are not looking
very good for putin this is only an
educated guess i'm not a military
expert well they can push back are you
actually suggesting you think the
ukrainians can win this
well again this is where idealism meets
realism and i can't give you an answer
on that but i would argue that if you're
looking at victory over the hearts minds
and souls of the rest of the world the
ukrainians have already done that and if
you're looking at defeat in terms of
showing the weakness of your military
then putin has already done that
so in that sense i would argue that
ukrainians have already won but then the
final issue here is the end state you
know is
are they going to be able to uh maintain
the independence and sovereignty of
ukraine uh and its territory that's
that's gonna be the key
we were just seeing a piece there from
ireland uh questioning their own
neutrality you know where does finland
stand on this on nato neutrality and all
those questions that have been prompted
by this war
well i i certainly wouldn't compare
finnish and irish neutrality because
ours uh during the cold war was one of
necessity uh with 1 340 kilometers of
border with russia
when the cold war ended we immediately
ditched the notion of neutrality join
the european union join the euro
a very close partnership with nato
participate in nato operations and also
in nato training our military is more
nato compatible than that of many member
states and we were very quick to send
arms to ukraine as well uh but this has
obviously shifted public opinion on nato
membership you know we used to be 50
against 24 now the latest opinion post
62 in favor of nato membership and 16
against so if i may predict with my
academic glasses on uh the trainers left
the station and eventually finland will
join nato
very interesting um so many implications
from this conflict certainly professor
alexander stubb former prime minister of
finland thank you very much indeed for
your time much appreciated
on the war in ukraine after an address
to the german parliament today we'll
talk about the ukrainian president's
campaign to build support for his
country around the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they've pushed the protesters further
back here as around two or three hundred
still remain
i'm dan whitehead and i'm sky news's
west of england correspondent
this fan goes on to the streets of
plymouth seven days a week 365 days a
year these facilities are at the moment
a lifesaver
[Music]
from fishing communities to bustling
cities we spend every day reporting from
across the region hearing from people
who have real stories
i have nowhere to live for
about three or four months
there are still people inside the
properties here
they're coming from the epicentre of
what is now a global health pandemic
we were seeing and speaking to young
women who were selling themselves
right on the high street it was
desperately sad and the fact it was
happening right in the hearts of this
community
before brexit these oysters were being
exported to the eu but the trade stopped
overnight
it's your feeling about the future
blake
i'd all be
finished i don't know
well ukraine's president zielinski has
addressed germany's parliament
this morning telling members that some
sanctions came too late to stop the war
we asked you about preventive sanctions
we
urged europe to many countries we urged
you
so such sanctions that the enemy felt
that you're a force but you delayed
we understood that you wanted to support
your economy economy economy
[Applause]
well over the past week mr zielinski has
certainly given a master class in how to
pitch his message to europe and united
states and canada indeed quoting
shakespeare and martin luther king and
taylor and his address with well chosen
historical parallels so let's talk more
i'm joined now by surah david wilke who
is the deputy director of the german
martial fund of the united states who
joins us from berlin
yes certainly quoting churchill to the
uk martin luther king as we heard
yesterday uh for america and what did
germany get to hear
hi good evening yes um you know germany
got to hear the metaphor of the wall um
president zielinski really urged germans
to think about their past and how today
a new wall is emerged holding back
freedom but the tone of the speech was
quite different than washington
yesterday and london earlier in the week
because
zielenski also took the opportunity to
sort of lay into germany
about past choices and also about
current links with russia so i think the
german government knew that
criticism was going to come and they did
receive that on the floor of the
bundestag today
so two issues that you mentioned there
one was i suppose the reluctance at the
start to provide
defensive munitions and and hardware uh
to ukraine uh the other one of course is
about the gas reliance i guess and that
relationship with with russia so first
of all give us a sense of why germany
was so slow in accepting that actually
you needed to arm the ukrainians to to
to be able to fight this fight
that's right i mean germany has now
ushered in a new era a cold a so-called
turning point um and we saw you know
signs of that even before the speech
that schultz gave in parliament three
weeks ago they decided to send lethal
weapons to ukraine and they also halted
nordstream 2. but unfortunately this
turning point
with germany becoming a credible
military power in europe
is not going to help ukraine today um
right now um you know there is concern
still that germany is dependent on
russia clearly this country is going to
try and wean itself off of
russian energy sources but right now
it's difficult because they are afraid
of economic repercussions
and obviously everybody's worried about
the what we're calling in the uk cost of
living crisis with the rising energy
bills that everybody will be facing how
much concern is there in germany about
that because of the gas situation but
also how much on the other hand is there
support for the ukrainian people what is
the balance
so the majority of germans have a lot of
sympathy for ukraine i mean the pictures
that um people are seeing in the news
are horrifying and obviously stir up
memories of the past i mean the past
the 30 years since the fall of the wall
have been
a
time for germany to really prosper and
it's been a status quo country but it's
realizing that the security architecture
is under threat in europe and of course
germany is also under threat but at the
same time the country is still trying to
hold on to its commercial interests
because
um a
embargo on russian energy would cause
disruption to um industry here and would
probably equal job losses at the same
time people here think they're ready to
make a sacrifice they think that they
could you know wear
warm clothes next winter and freeze for
freedom in ukraine but i think they're
they don't realize that german industry
also requires energy from russia in
order to keep humming and because
nuclear energy is off the table at the
end of the year and germany wants to be
carbon free um their gas technol gas
from russia is the bridge
that's being used right now until this
green transformation could take place
it's interesting isn't it because there
has been criticism of germany at the
start of all of this from the us and
from the uk
and yet you know germany as a nation
knows about the influence of of the
soviet union with east germany for so
many years
so is is there a sense there too of the
importance of needing to push back
you know russian nationalism and the
need for for a greater russia
well you know berlin was the center of
the cold war and it's really interesting
now that ukraine is now
the pinnacle of um defending freedom in
europe and for the rest of our
democracies and i think um
germany
remembers the fall of the wall as also
being a time when um daetant with russia
also played a role but many people
forget here that
the so-called aus politic of billy
brandt and other leaders in germany also
took place under the backdrop of
deterrence and as i mentioned the past
30 years um germany had a respite from
history and forgot that military
power is also needed to safeguard our
democracy
has this brought europe together has
this brought nato together you know are
there upsides to any of this
right i think um putin inadvertently um
didn't realize that his actions as um
aggression against ukraine the war that
he's now unleashed has uh brought the
western alliance together like it never
has been before
it's
given great resolve to um
nato nato was actually probably tr going
under an identity crisis over the last
couple of years you remember that
president macron had called nato
brain dead and
had also undergone much abuse from the
trump administration
but the cohesion
among western capitals is quite
impressive the question is how long will
this be sustainable um and
with germany investing now in its
military a hundred
billion euro fund for defense and a
commitment to reach the two percent
nato um commitment
is um you know gonna open up new
opportunities for security cop right
cooperation within europe and also um
make germany a leader in europe we have
uh we've
sudo we've run out of time lovely to
have you on suda david wilt they're
talking to us from berlin thank you
but that was a sky news special on the
war in ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you